oh my hair is really strong
yeah
that's so clear
how cool that's our baby's heart
[Music]
how are you guys today i am doing very
well
thanks for asking yeah so today i
actually wanted to talk about
how my pregnancy has been
so far
and i actually wanted to show you guys
all this like pregnancy stuff that i've
gotten recently because i think it's
really funny and up until this point
i've been kind of like putting off
documenting a lot of pregnancy things
um because
we hadn't told you guys yet and i don't
know it just felt better to just be like
okay i'll just tell them later i'll tell
them later so now is the later and now i
want to show you guys some of the stuff
that i've gotten some of how i've been
feeling uh to date with the pregnancy
because a lot of you guys are so happy
for us thank you so much we're so happy
too we're so happy to bring you on this
journey with us i am
so so grateful for all of you guys
messages all of your love and your
support just being so happy for us and
also a lot of the people that have hit
me up and shared that they've also gone
through their struggles with their
fertility and um just you know that
hearing our story has given them a lot
of hope which has made me feel so
honored that i've even been able to make
an impact on you guys like that both
casey and i like our experience have
been able to make an impact on you guys
and so
humbling and heartwarming and i just i
really love receiving your guys's
messages and reading your guys's
comments you guys are so loving and so
supporting and just want to say thank
you for that anyway let's jump into the
pregnancy stuff so for starters let's
talk about
that that's not a person under there or
i guess um we could personify
the item underneath the sheets here but
this has been
my most comfortable
buy
for this pregnancy and it is a pregnancy
pillow look at that baby this thing
right here has now replaced casey as my
cuddle buddy he's not very happy about
that but i'm very happy because it's so
comfortable i sleep like a baby in this
i literally sleep like as if i'm in like
i'm in a cocoon i just feel like a like
a baby again so now that the baby is
growing this little belly is growing it
has been been more and more comfortable
but i've actually had this pillow
right around the same time that we got
our new helix sleep mattress which by
the way thank you helixly for sponsoring
today's video we are super excited to
partner with them because they make
premium mattresses and bedding
customized to fit your needs and they
deliver it straight to your door so what
you do first is you take their sleep
quiz and you will find out which
mattress best fits your body type and
your sleep preferences so for example
casey and i we share this bed we took
the sleep quiz and we are we both found
out that we're both side sleepers and we
both love super soft mattresses and
helix matched us with their helix sunset
luxe mattress it is so freaking
comfortable and it has been the greatest
change to our sleeping habits ever
especially now with me starting this
pregnancy or like almost halfway through
this pregnancy i have definitely seen a
difference in my quality of sleep i
actually wake up much more rested my
back used to hurt before because our
mattress was getting pretty old before
but now ever since we switched over to
helix my back doesn't hurt anymore and
even though this pregnancy is still
keeping me up at night to go pee all the
time as soon as i laid back down to
sleep i am knocked out immediately like
this bed is so comfortable and i just
made it even more comfortable with this
pillow here so i'm raving about it it's
i'm really getting my best night's sleep
now these days and it's really cool
because they actually do free delivery
and they offer a 100 night sleep trial
so you get more than three months to try
out helix and see if you actually fall
in love with the mattress that they
match you up with and if you don't no
big deal they'll just come pick it up
and give you a full refund and what's
really cool is that all mattresses come
with a 10 year warranty and they also
offer flexible payment options pretty
cool so if you're in the market for a
new mattress make sure to check out
helix and you can do that by going to
helixsleep.com
tiffcase for up to 200 off your helix
mattress and trust me
i absolutely love it this baby is
getting a good night's sleep in this
mattress and also with this pillow so
back to the pregnancy stuff this pillow
oh my goodness like i said i am wrapped
up in here like a cocoon so i get in
here put my arm through and like i said
this mattress is so comfy made more
comfortable
when i put it between my legs like this
and then look it's hugging
for my back too ah it's so comfortable
i'm just in here
forever like i don't even know how many
hours i spend in this bed anymore
because i just never want to get out
even though i feel really well rested in
the morning by the time i'm up it's just
so freaking comfortable i don't want to
move like why would you want to leave
this
wonderful most comfortable cocoon
with this most wonderful comfortable
mattress but anyway moving on from the
sleep stuff so that has changed in my
life
next look at my nightstand
well first of all look at this uh
medicine ball here so i purchased this
ball because obviously hello it's teal
it's beautiful it's my favorite color
yeah i got one of these because i read
that it's really
it's really helpful for when you're in
labor but not just that before you go
into labor it's really helpful in
getting the baby into position so with
isaac he was actually breached which
means that his head was up instead of
like down so i ended up having to get a
c-section with him for that reason i
wasn't able to have a natural birth with
him and so now with this pregnancy i'm
like oh my gosh what can i do to make
sure
baby gets in position and a lot of the
tips that i'm reading it's like oh make
sure you do yoga you go walking when you
sit down don't lean back make sure you
like stay forward and like just have
really good posture
um and then also get yourself one of
these medicine balls and do like some
like hip rotation situation stuff
or like bouncing you could do like this
like a figure eight with your hips you
can do some squats there's a whole bunch
of stuff you can do with this ball so
whenever i'm just hanging out here in
the room watching some tv i just sit my
butt down on this ball and just try to
like
get into the groove of
having it and just using it
so hopefully it will help me
help the baby be in the proper position
anyway yeah so that's a pregnancy item
i've purchased recently oh and then also
oh my god this thing has been amazing
for my tailbone and my lower back like
by me sitting a lot because
i just i sit a lot these days
or i lay down in bed a lot there ends up
being a lot of pressure on my tailbone
and my lower back but ever since getting
this ball and just like bouncing on it
like i feel like it has tremendously
alleviated that pressure on my my
tailbone and my lower back so i've been
loving this ball i love it moving on to
the rest of the things right here so i
always got my water bottle i bought a
humidifier because it's been very
helpful with the ac on during the summer
like my whole like nasal
respiratory system
stuff has been really dry but every
night i connected it to the google home
so i'll be like hey google good night
and then when i say that it'll turn off
all the lights that i have connected
with the the smart dimmers that i talked
about before i'll turn off all the
lights and then it'll
actually turn on this humidifier and
then i have it set to turn
off in the morning so i have a
humidifier humidifier on the whole night
and sleep really comfortable i really
love this thing i actually have to fill
it back up it's already empty okay this
i bought these
tummy drops which are like some ginger
candies during my first trimester
because oh my gosh was i freaking
nauseous the whole time i was super
nauseous it was really really weird too
because like i i will
love a dish like some food like one
moment and then the next or like crave
it and then the next moment even if i
haven't even eaten that dish that i was
craving i will just think about it and
it will make me want to vomit like it
was pretty bad so another thing that i
purchased was this thing
what is this nozzology i found this on
i found this on amazon and i actually
bought the variety pack so this is
peppermint there was a lemon one and a
ginger one and the ginger one oh my god
it was disgusting do not recommend that
one but i really like the peppermint one
and what it is it's this like inhaler
thing
so you smell it and it just smells like
peppermint it immediately erased all the
nausea that
i'd be feeling so
it smells really good too i really like
the peppermint one like these two things
really helped me a lot
with my nausea in the first trimester
highly recommend it actually the tummy
drops not really i don't really
recommend these actually take it back
because you can see i didn't really eat
a lot of them
like it's practically still
full
but i do recommend this one like big
time recommend this thing moving on to
the rest of my nightstand okay apple
watch whatever chapstick whatever um
i bought this baby doppler so this is
freaking exciting do you guys know what
this is do you know what a doppler is
it's so i can hear the baby's heartbeat
and this thing came with
this gel so it can help like boost up
the
sound or whatever so you could hear it
so it's pretty much like getting an
ultrasound at home but only to hear the
baby's heartbeat
and
it's pretty cool
what are you doing
hearing the baby's heartbeat
[Music]
it's not that fast
oh yeah it's different yeah
that's the second heartbeat of my body
yeah she said it was 160 today but
oh the baby's moving
[Music]
the baby's moving
look at that
[Music]
you're so cute
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah it's pretty awesome it's not as
great as the ones in the doctor's office
obviously like it's
still a little like
cheapy but
i got it um
amazon it was like 60 bucks
get to hear the baby's heartbeat
actually this has been really handy
because i tripped the other day
um
last week actually it was last week i
tripped on a curb like the curb was like
this big and i stepped on it because i
thought it was just the floor i didn't
notice that it was a curb because it was
like super super little and my ankle
gave out and i actually got this
scratched up on my knee
when i tumbled to the floor
i landed mostly on that knee that has a
nasty scrape so like i initially landed
on my knee that's where most of the
impact was but then at the end of it i
did kind of fall on my hip and so i was
really scared because i was getting a
little bit of
some cramps and when i got home as soon
as i got home i'm like oh my god let me
check the baby's heartbeat is the baby
okay is everything all right and yeah
the baby was good and ever since then i
don't feel baby move anymore because
i've been feeling baby move more often
but like certain days i won't feel the
baby move at all so then i'm like okay
let me hear the heartbeat like is
everything okay so i'm a little bit
paranoid
but this has been like helping me be at
ease so i do recommend a doppler at
least you can hear the baby's heartbeat
and everything will be okay so that's
the doppler
and then obviously i'm gonna have tahin
at my bedside this is actually new that
casey found at the grocery store so i
guess it's the heen's way of trying to
be chamoy so some sauce i actually
haven't used it much and then these guys
oh my god these are pickle chips
from trader joe's pickled potato chips
highly recommend these are so bomb and
if you open this
i got way more snacks in here
so oh yeah my tums
these are lifesaver i've been getting
tons of heartburn these have been coming
through
some pretzels this was actually
empty and i recently filled it back up
and i just got a whole bunch of other
things in here just to like especially
these guys these guys came through in
the first trimester big time too just
having them on my nightstand like as
soon as i wake up i'm like okay let me
get some saltine crackers or some
pretzels
because i'm gonna throw up
and it really helped a lot like this
whole corner of this room
it's like okay a pregnant lady lives
here for sure and then i see this in the
corner
i did want to mention a huge thank you
to antoine
our former slash kind of current editor
but yeah antoine he's so freaking sweet
you guys he
has been the very first person even
before me or casey to purchase something
for the baby as soon as like after we
told
um we told him that we were pregnant he
sent over a gift through amazon and open
it i actually i packaged it back up
because i'm like oh my gosh this is so
pretty i gotta save it but yeah he
he's the very first person to gift this
baby something that means so much hold
on let me open this
oh look at this
look you guys he got the baby a bath
hoodie how cute
it's a little elephant it's an elephant
bath hoodie and that is just the
sweetest most thoughtful gift ever thank
you so much antoine if you're watching
this
i
freaking cried i cried when i opened
this and it was just so overwhelming
like
the fact that we have our very first
baby thing this is the very first thing
that our baby
owns in their entire life
so i don't know it really meant a lot to
me thank you so much antoine and
speaking of gifts let's go to the garage
because i have something else to show
you guys okay so i'm in the garage now
and i came here to show you guys another
gift that has been gifted to
this baby here can you see it right here
it's a crib
our
wonderful neighbors ryan and lily they
gifted us their crib and their their
changing table so this thing right here
is
a changing table and the mattress
and then the crib pieces right there too
and i'm like oh my god we have a crib
already this is incredible i can't
believe it so the thing is that we are
well i'm i'm trying to get one of those
like smart cribs that the baby can grow
into until they're like two years old
but it like rocks your baby and it has
like sounds and all kinds of fancy stuff
it's like really expensive too but their
waiting list is like forever so who
knows if we'll even be able to get it in
time for the baby besides all that
though um our neighbors they this crib
has actually been passed down from a
family member of theirs so it's actually
been already
a hand-me-down before so they were like
oh just you know have it just in case if
you need it
and if you don't you end up getting that
other crib no big deal you guys can sell
this one or whatever but
how thoughtful of them though they
actually were like you know what you
guys take it you guys can have the crib
if you need it so i think this the kit
like the original baby that first used
this crib i think that baby is about
isaac's age right now so it's a pretty
old crib
but it has lasted through the years
through the babies because our neighbors
they have two kids and both of their
kids use this crib
and yeah and so they were like if you
guys need a crib there you go you can
have it so i'm like
this is so cool like that's so sweet
like it warmed my heart so much to know
that so many people already love this
baby so much are you guys excited for
your new sibling
yeah are you excited you want me to feed
you huh you don't even know what i'm
talking about
cutie oh and then this girl right here
she is so sweet every night when we go
to sleep she's just purring away
cuddling with me and then this guy he
for sure knows i'm pregnant hey hey hey
hey hold on we're vlogging right now
but he knows that i'm pregnant because
he actually avoids
stepping on my belly these days it's so
cute seeing how they've been
they've been reacting to the pregnancy
are you still sniffing her butt
go away
you weirdo and look how sweet
my husband
bought me flowers
look how pretty these flowers are i love
them it makes me happy oh but you know
what else i purchased too
recently that is so freaking cute it's
in the office so we're gonna have to go
disturb
baby
knock knock
hey what's up hey you're editing i'm
ending a vlog that our doctor visits
nice the doctor the doctor sent me to
the doctor
you're so funny i always say things like
that
no i came in here because i wanted to
show them
this
so look at this you guys i purchased
this golden rainbow it's here for now
because i haven't put it up on the wall
yet i'm trying to figure out where to
put it but you know how like our baby's
a rainbow baby but it's gold i was
actually thinking about putting it
somewhere on this wall maybe like
scooting this over or something because
there's like there's room here not my
cafe picture no they're just scooting it
over i screwed it all up
i don't know because the whole idea with
this wall was to like create like a
gallery wall you were supposed to buy
more things i nothing spoke to me like
the way this picture did and i just
never
yeah it's like put things around it just
to like fill in the wall but i don't
know i got this thing so i'm like maybe
maybe you could go
somewhere there
i don't know about right here but it'd
be kind of weird behind the door or i
was thinking about having it
here
that's kind of cute or maybe here but it
might be too big for the space but yeah
that golden
rainbow just spoke to me i was like i
need to have it our baby must have it
our baby
our baby look at look at your baby
you can talk to it every morning every
night yeah say good morning good night
hope you're floating around in there
enjoying all the yummy food moms eating
yeah okay seconds it's happy seconds but
you know what it's so cute we haven't
talked about it in the vlog what what's
your nickname for the baby oh i we've
been calling it the astronaut you
started calling him the astronauts yeah
okay i was watching and it's not not
like that i'm expecting this baby to
join ass or anything like has nothing to
do with that join what nasa oh i heard
ass
so i started calling our baby an
astronaut because
when we went to the first ultrasound
and like we made contact with the daisy
i was like
yo it's an astronaut it's like it's not
extraterrestrial but it's like
inner
mamma estral yeah it was like inside you
you know so i was like whoa we're making
contact and it's like
they're all floating too like moving
yeah they're just like in like an empty
void like in the ultrasound they're just
like in this like pitch blackness and
there's like this little tiny dot and i
was like oh they're like floating like
an astronaut yeah i've been calling an
astronaut ever since yeah our little
astronaut baby plus the umbilical cord i
can imagine is kind of like the the
oxygen core yeah they're like pulling
back to the space station
that's so true yeah so we've been
calling this baby an astronaut
sometimes
i wake up and i feel like i have zero
belly like the baby disappeared and i'm
not pregnant anymore and i'm like what
the heck i don't have like anything like
zero belly but then i'll have my first
meal and then the baby pops out actually
man it looks like i actually have a
belly like a big belly i guess i do you
do have a belly yeah
you can't hide it no more
this baby's sticking out but yeah that's
been the journey you guys
thank you for following along
um we'll be sure to document a lot more
for you
now in real time instead of just in
retrospect like this vlog
but yeah it's really exciting but yeah
anyway thanks for watching see you guys
next time peace bye
[Music]
oh like remixing the heartbeat dj
champs
[Music]
so
[Music]